[Musica]
il gioco the sims mi ha sempre
affascinato come puoi creare dei
personaggi dargli fare caratteristiche e
controllare completamente la loro vita
ma se invece fossero i personaggi dei
sims a controllare la nostra di vita
cosa succederebbe bene la decisione ha
ridotto il figlio sono vita lui e
merlino e così nuova challenge
fantastica faremo per 24 ore quello che
fanno i nostri semplice io e merlino
faremo per 24 ore quello che sono i
nostri sims quindi il mio team comanderà
la mia vita per 24 ore qualsiasi cosa
farà per quanto tempo marra dovrò farlo
anch'io come abbiamo fatto per
organizzare questa challenge grazie a
vitale di tale ha ricostruito tutta
questa casa in cui stiamo adesso e ha
ricostruito quasi ogni minimo dettaglio
grazie a questi dettagli potrò
riprodurre esattamente cosa farà il mio
team durante la giornata o un po di
paura che faccia qualcosa di strano ma
lasciate un bel mi piace perché questa
sarà una challenge super pazzesca
e se questo video raggiunge il 45 mila
mi piace farò anche la seconda parte
potete consigliere voi nei commenti le
regole per la seconda parte cosa si può
scarno e mettetevi comodi e iniziamo
subito la challenge per ridere la
challenge devo innanzitutto trasformarli
nel mio team siete pronti 32 buon allora
eccomi trasformata ora vediamo un po
cosa fai il mio team a partire dalla
mattina ok allora la prima cosa
usare di prima mattina non è mangiare o
andare in bagno ma di non dare al
computer
abbiamo giocato più per non vedo l'ora
non so perché ma non userò il mio
computer ma userò quello digitale perché
perché
ok sono bastati dodici minuti e ora il
mio team ha deciso di alzarsi a
carezzare berlino e se di valutare
beh direi che questa parte del film mi
piace hanno dovuto parlare come sib
beh direi che il pm mi conosce
abbastanza bene queste maschere sono
sempre quattro divano berlino calo dell
ok ora praticamente il mio team ha
deciso di stare seduta del divano ferma
marino fiscalità chiari tel
berlino che hai mangiato è ora 11 di
mattina
cosa fa la mia sim papa relazione al
bagno
thorne giocare computer però questa
volta a tetris bravo e bello socrates e
tonino martino sottopaga il mio team
come si no
non so perché il mio figlio lo trovò
super divertente arriva in continuazione
giocando a tennis
la cosa divertente
e poi è un certo punto ha detto perché
ma decide di giocare stanno tutti del
vero incubo ora non gli si decide di
salire nuovamente su per andare in
camera e spazzolare merlino ovviamente
senza avere ancora fatto colazione
essere andata in bagno
siamo in camera ma dell'idv medica
berlina bravo bravo chiuso a berlino
berlino devo farlo ma portal ha detto la
bf berlino vuole giocare ma ora a
mezzogiorno a 22
invece lì invece di pranzare la mia
singola ha deciso di tornare a giocare a
the sims
divertente tu sei una diva tinta all'ora
di pranzo senza aver fatto colazione
eppure la mia sim decide di andare in
cucina finalmente speriamo che mangerò
qualcosa sto morendo di fame
però non so per quale assurdo motivo
invece di andare con cena da li decide
di uscire poi vorrà dare così da
ovviamente molto logico quindi usciamo
fuori
[Musica]
e vivono queste cose qualcosa finalmente
ma no la mia sim ha deciso di prendere
dal frigo un bicchiere d'acqua
va benissimo vorrebbe dire e poi beve
l'acqua fissando il primo come facciamo
tutti i nomadi giorno sono passati
quindici minuti
ora la mia firma ha deciso di andare di
nuovo su ma come il bicchiere d'acqua
andiamo ok rispondiamo per la terza
volta con il migliore l'altra comerio
sconcertate mi separa una padroncina di
essa per frey ma dopo aver lodato
merlino ernestino ha deciso di fissare
il muro congiunto bicchiere o meno male
è troppo divertente la vita disistima
nel frattempo berlino che sta masticando
sui pieni berlino l'animale che perché
non ci sarà il muro alle 2010
finalmente posso andare in bagno
andiamo in bagno che proprio qui e ora
possa tirare l'acqua e lavare le mani
[Musica]
che evita divertente
che non si prende una torta che facciamo
mangiare
no un bicchiere d'acqua ma non ha
mangiato niente però i consumi d'acqua
preso ovviamente se va bene davanti al
frigo ma questi diversamente se vuole
che continua a fissare il primo bene
l'acqua per 23 minuti ma che facciamo è
terribile perché così la vita dei figli
potrebbero decidere di far parte di cosa
hanno deciso di prenderla stato tutto in
frigo
che dibattimento possa abitare mi rimane
per 18 minuti
e proprio la mia giornata ideale
tutto quello che è stato il divano
pensamenti lui festante ma naturalmente
dai 18.000 città lo deve fissare dei
piedi non può essere artefici wow
finalmente posso smettere privato e
salire su convivono moltissimo bicchiere
d'acqua nella versione tanto ma vabbè se
risaliamo sa fare cassa ma stavolta ora
deciso di appoggiare il bicchiere
intoppi che sono trasformati in un
pianto per le cose
partiamo ovviamente che si salva
ovviamente per mettere il paziente
questa è la quarta tutti gli alberi non
si possa credere
sto tornando al frigo considera fuori
dal frigo provate a indovinare mi
commenti di questo film sicuramente
molto degradato
peccato che non ha mangiato niente
scacciarla dovresti fissare con un po il
frigo la tv per un bel po di minuti a
nicola nel frattempo sta andando la
lavastoviglie che evita chi sia ma molto
dire tante tormentare la rete continua a
fissare su ibra bastano mai avvenire
come la visti
decide di spostarsi e andare a fare
chissà quale cose ma al di là si fa
sedere sul divano troppo divertente e
tema vi serve nuovamente da cane buon
movimento un'altra cosa inizialmente che
fa la bimba adesso è fissare un quadro
che divertente ma 14 30 minuti basta non
voglio più particolare questa carne che
vita noiosa
ora capisco perché dobbiamo controllarli
noi film non fa castelletti farebbero se
lo fa da secoli
rispettato e non mangiare globale moria
che subito trova da mesi ma è molto
felice per te ed i magistrati che si sta
richiamo culturalmente è troppo
divertente che questo quadro prendiamo
il in fregola prime il nostro immagini
solito bicchiere d'acqua
no questa volta c'è un'altra cosa che si
sa di credere
niente
pregano formati marina questo è quello
informatico non c'erano squadra fino a
detta è bellissimo angelo a ripeter con
molta lentezza e con il ditta tipo per
45 minuti quindi dovrei mangiare molto
molto lentamente scena le chiama scusa
ma questo non c'era mentre senso tolta
questo questo esserino qui che sta
all'angolo questa aspetta nemmeno le tre
prime a mangiare per 45 minuti dovrei
stare questi che dovrà sopportare
berlino che cerca di farsi il cibo
berlino adesso novanta era il partner
ovviamente la mia sim mentre mangia è
molto divertita e parlata
l'impiegato al formaggio giustamente
giustamente un'altra cosa in regalo
giusto per mantenere la loro trasferta e
freschezza scelte pratiche tiffany che
il frigo e per essere più mosci del
mondo minino berlino berlino ritira
comunque dopo 45 minuti indovino e che
così va in rovina tutto nostra cosa
trasferito e anche quello non deve molto
lentamente tipo per altri 45 minuti
il talentino poco stando seduto a cui i
[Musica]
timpani
e arrivato il momento di prendere il mio
bicchiere d'acqua
questa dunque la seduta europa per
formare una nuova espansione investite
la maledizione del bicchiere d'acqua
perfetto quelli che hanno la mostra
tanto i breakers profumatissimi e adesso
ci spiega il 40 il mondiale per avere
finalmente 25 mar i bandi assiste alla
tappa sembra tosta medica via così
[Musica]
così interessata cosa è vero che il
governo di lavare le mani come sapete si
lavano conflitti almeno così anche se
non si è fatta la doccia stamattina
toccherà mettiamo le mani per fare
inoltre compatibile molti è vero è molto
più moderate di fissare il primo con un
bicchiere d'acqua e barocche giocare la
tua sim gioia si ma anche nella vita
reale
il section non è possibile giocare team
io sta riproducendo la mia sim che gioca
stimava dentro il team sta giocando è
troppo statico e stop allenatore
mourinho spende momento quella del gioco
non sta giocando a sipps stai guardando
una partita di calcio fifa in me non
piangere bene il caso lo capisco niente
di calcio
ma questo perché tu stai stai giocando a
simili non perché lei sta giocando a
sims non so se mi spiego
aspetta aspetta ora sto competente
guarda quello nel gioco sei tu che stai
giocando a sims non sims che sta
giocando fatto che stai giocando un
gioco finito di caricare novembre
sperano di fronte al frega
[Musica]
questa sia la parte più divertente di
tutto il giorno perfetto per fortuna la
mia sim mettendo a fare cose divertenti
e ora niente cosa facciamo ora in studio
che john f i cambi e vogliono dormire
passate le nove e bertolo possa servire
dove beh se poi non si è anche il mio
letto che però era bello fai tu voglio
vedere nel mio letto e quello cooper
olivo amarezza sono ci sarà neanche le
coperte
berlino berlino vuole dormire nel letto
ti prego quindi se la prossima deciso
andare a dormire alle 9 25 tu ti devi
cambiare come latina volta andare a
dormire le tv
che bello cambiarsi così vado a dormire
alle nove e mezza bella testa indietro
la luce che devo dormire berlino tu mi
guardi scioccato ma io devo dormire col
toro come stagista davvero molto
interessante io ho scoperto che la vita
di sì un po particolare un po monotona
se non la controlliamo noi forse è
meglio controllarla noi così rendiamo le
cose un po più divertenti che hanno
letto una traccia le giuste senso
lasciato un bel mi piace a 45 mila mi
piace fare un'altra challenge sui the
sims
se avete visto il video fino a qua
scrivete nei commenti la maledizione del
bicchiere d'acqua e ora vi lascio qua 4
candeline su cui vicari per vedere i
nostri altri video cliccate su quella
che proprio lì da giorni no di berlino
perplesso dice ma che è stata farsi a
quanti team bello